So since finding a mathematical proof for showing the intractability of the problems that
Alice, Bob, and Carol are working on seems to be rather hard,
we're first going to start with gathering evidence that their problems might be intractable.
Of course, we don't yet really know if their problems really are intractable
because as we have just seen there are also arguments why their problems
could actually be tractable because just having an exponential number of solutions
does not necessarily mean that their problems are difficult but we're going to see how it turns out.
So how can we gather evidence that the problems of Alice, Bob, and Carol could be intractable?
One way could be what we have done in the last unit and that is if you recall in the last unit
we showed that all of these three problems are either tractable or intractable.
So one way to gather evidence that they are intractable is to find more and more problems
for which we also don't know polynomial time algorithms
and connect them to the problems that we know.
So if we had this huge network of problems but we say if we find a polynomial time algorithm
for just one of them, all of them would be solvable in polynomial time
but nobody has yet found such an algorithm that would already be rather strong evidence that
also clique, vertex cover, and independent set might be hard.
So we might, for example, end up with thousands of highly relevant problems
for which no one has so far found a polynomial time algorithm
and if they're all connected that would be not a mathematical proof but it would be
a somewhat convincing body of evidence for these problems' hardness.
And in fact, I will introduce you to such a collection of problems at the end of this unit
and we'll also have a closer look in the next units.
But today actually, we're going to do something that is a little bolder.
We're still not going to be able to achieve a mathematical proof of intractability
but we're going to do something that I would say is somewhere in between
gathering evidence and a mathematic proof.
And the way we're going to do this is as follows.
I'm going to introduce to you a type of computer that is extremely powerful.
So powerful in fact that no one has ever conceived if it could actually be built.
And then what I'll show you is that if there was a polynomial time algorithm for vertex cover
or clique or independent set, that would be like having a blueprint for this super powerful computer.
We won't be able to show that it's imposible to build such a computer,
but it is pretty good evidence that those three problems up here are very tough problems to solve.
So what makes this computer that I'm about to introduce to you so powerful?
Well, roughly speaking, it's so powerful because it has the capability to guess things for us
and it will guess them correctly but you're going to see in a minute what I mean by that.
First of all, let's have a look once more at the three problems: click, vertex cover, and independent set.
And have a look at how a machine that would be capable of guessing things for us
could potentially make the solution to these problems very easy.
And we're going to do this as a quiz and what I would like you to think about is
what the three problems we have been talking about so far have in common.
And I'm going to give you a number of choices and I would like you to tell me
which ones of these you think are true and there can be more than one.
So there's four possible choices here and again more than one of these can be true.
So what do all of these three problems up here have in common?
Choice #1, we have not found a polynomial time algorithm for them yet.
Choice #2, they are not practically relevant.
Choice #3, the simple algorithms that we have found so far
go through an exponential number of solutions.
And finally, for the simple algorithms, for any given 0 and 1 assignment to the vertices
so we have already assigned the values of 0 and 1 to them, it is relatively easy to figure out
if that assignment is a valid solution.
And if it is a valid solution, how large that solution is? So please check all of these that are correct.